haven't used it before but now I'm
trying Rogaine how to use it for black
men follow me and I'll show you how to
use rogaine for black men you don't want
your stuff to be ending up like Sherman
Helmsley you don't want a goof go on
George Jefferson
no one can create a viral video and
anyone that says to you that can make a
viral video it's going to be liners but
you cannot reverse engineer a viral
video 72 hours of video uploaded to
YouTube every minute less than three
percent of videos upload to you to go
over 1,000 views hi my name is David wha
and I'm an entertainer living in Los
Angeles I've been given seven chances to
create a viral video this is my
adventure and I invite you to come on
with me can I go viral can we tell you
what took y'all want to like Tara okay
go there we go I was awesome she's so
naughty she's so naughty yeah yeah oh
come on oh come on up no that's that's
crazy because I I've talked to a couple
of my friends who are like in their 50s
or in their 40s or 60s and engines are
still waiting for that break to happen
and you know it could be a combination
of things I mean people got to
understand this industry this business
it's like a lottery ticket you know and
sometimes your numbers may hit and
sometimes your numbers may not at the
end of the day you just gotta tell
yourself that you tried where we at your
place and I was like I was like yeah
just like so where is it that way right
and it was my car yeah that my car for a
minute yeah oh my god forbid I think for
like a year for like a year so yeah it
was crazy too cuz i would what i would
do is i would like switch up and I would
go to like it so crazy cuz i have like a
gym membership so i would take a shower
at the gym kick it go nestle back in the
car but yeah it was kind of crazy it was
one of those yeah who's that hard year
and I like
hard year in LA yeah I had this terrible
problem i first started it was a 19 but
was it it was in 1974 might have been
night sent for in 1984 Cadillac Caprice
rusty blue I even got pictures i'll show
you guys it was the worst car and I
remember when like when I would drive
fire engines and stuff would like if
they would if they were had an emergency
like they would just stop and let me go
because my car was just like a bus the
was just like it was it was crazy
and i would use like these terrible
green sheets they were kind of like my
little curtains to like so I could take
a nap or something like that and and the
seats weren't leather seats they were
like polyester seeds or something and it
would be a hot day and i would smell
like these terrible whoever had the car
before me honestly i would hope people
be like what them what the is he
will be rotor like what is that and it
was because whatever was in those those
seats like cuz it was some old-school
cut like old-school conscious like your
grandma had that would you take the
plastic off with him like it was like
that it was like those terrible couches
and that's how the seats where it was
disaster and people like oh my gosh and
it would be some it would be some term
with it and then the thing is in the hot
summer tech like I would pretend like I
had AC and I didn't have no AC so people
will see me sweating talk about starving
aren't like starving artists thank you
had the autumn of light do I guess I'm
to eat or do I put some gas in my car
it's kind of shaking off like going to
the restroom just want a little shake
right in there is you want to get all
that ten dollar we get all that ten
dollars worth of gas so you just got to
do a little bit of shape just so you can
get every day all in there there you go
right there there's a little bit in
advance as growing up I had just let you
know I was dyslexic bad acne fat just
every negative that you could think of
and it's just like at the end of the day
like those demons still haunt me to this
day it's just like
who's that fat pimple chubby kid you
know like so those things that's kind of
like who's that David wall you know so
at the end of the day it's just you
gotta think to yourself like you know
who is a wall and what is he going up
against and you know I think at the end
of the day for me it's kind of like even
though i feel like i still haven't
accomplished my dream i still don't want
to disappoint that kid who's watched TV
and said I'm gonna be there right there
having that acceptance speech so that's
the thing is I don't want to disappoint
that kid who watch TV every day every
night hoping one day to be there so I'm
doing it for him the little David wahoo
dreamed about it so yeah join me David
war for the next episode of can I go
viral well I will soon attempt to make a
viral YouTube video